Kaedah pengedaran kuantum berasaskan sampel atau SQD secara ringkas ialah algoritma hibrid kuantum-klasik seperti Krylov
pengedaran kuantum KQD seperti VQE dan banyak lagi. Bila guna algoritma hibrid
sedemikian, berguna untuk fikirkan di mana setiap algoritma memanfaatkan pengkomputeran kuantum dan klasik. Ingat bahawa VQE mencipta keadaan pada circuit kuantum
menggunakan parameter yang dioptimumkan secara klasik. Dalam kes tu, keadaan itu sendiri ada pada komputer kuantum. Tapi
mendapatkan keadaan sasaran ialah proses yang menggabungkan pengkomputeran klasik dan kuantum.
Nilai jangkaan operator dikira menggunakan pengukuran kuantum.
Tapi beberapa penggabungan sebutan secara klasik juga perlu.
Sebaliknya, SQD guna komputer kuantum untuk hasilkan subruang yang berguna di mana Hamiltonian atau operator lain boleh
diprojekkan. Hamiltonian kemudiannya didiagonalkan sepenuhnya secara klasik untuk cari keadaan sasaran. Katakan kita ada
masalah yang menarik untuk sains atau industri yang boleh dibentuk sebagai masalah penyelesai nilai eigen pada matriks n baris dan
n lajur. Andaikan lagi n cukup besar sehingga pengedaran klasik tepat bukan satu pilihan. Ia
jelas menguntungkan untuk kurangkan dimensi matriks kita sambil mengekalkan semua ciri-ciri relevan keadaan asas. Memang, itulah
matlamat banyak pendekatan penyelesai nilai eigen anggaran, termasuk kaedah krylov klasik. Anggaplah kita tahu cukup tentang masalah kita untuk buat
tekaan yang cukup baik tentang bentuk keadaan asas, tapi tak cukup untuk selesaikan masalah terus. Dalam kes
tu, kita boleh buat banyak pengukuran anggaran yang munasabah bagi keadaan asas sasaran. Keputusan
pengukuran memberi kita subruang keadaan asas pengiraan yang mengandungi semua komponen relevan
keadaan asas. Memproyeksikan ke subruang tu akan hasilkan matriks yang lebih kecil yang masih mengandungi darjah kebebasan yang relevan
Aliran kerja untuk ini adalah seperti berikut. Kau mulakan dengan memilih ansatz yang bagus.
Lebih tepat, pilih ansatz yang sokongannya bertepatan dengan keadaan sasaran. Kita akan bincangkan dengan tepat apa
maksudnya. Seterusnya, ukur keadaan dalam asas pengiraan seperti yang dilakukan dengan primitif sampler.
Kemudian, guna keputusan pensampelan untuk tentukan subruang yang mengandungi keadaan asas.
Kemudian, projek matriks kau ke subruang tu. Akhirnya, diagonalkan matriks yang diprojek yang lebih kecil secara klasik.
Jom urai setiap langkah ini, dengan perhatian khusus pada menentukan subruang.
Sepanjang pengkomputeran kuantum, memilih ansatz yang bagus sentiasa kritikal. Dalam kes SQD, pilihan ansatz kau
akan tentukan keadaan asas pengiraan yang mungkin diukur dalam pensampelan.
Keadaan asas sebenar boleh dinyatakan sebagai superposisi beberapa subset keadaan asas pengiraan. Subset tu
dipanggil sokongan keadaan asas. Untuk dapatkan anggaran yang baik bagi keadaan asas dan tenaganya, ansatz kau
mesti ada unjuran bukan-sifar ke keadaan asas pengiraan dalam sokongan keadaan asas.
Gambarajah ini mewakili ruang yang direntangi oleh semua keadaan yang mungkin pada bilangan qubit yang digunakan. Kita nak
ansatz dengan sokongan yang mengandungi sokongan keadaan asas sebenar.
Pertimbangkan sistem contoh yang sangat kecil dengan keadaan asas s asas ialah 8 *
keadaan 1 0 0 tambah 6 * keadaan 001.
Ini ada sokongan yang terdiri daripada dua vektor 1 0 0 dan 0 1. Katakan ansatz berbentuk ANSATZ 1 ialah A kali
keadaan 1 0 0 tambah B * keadaan 0 1 0 tambah C * keadaan 001. Supaya
sokongannya ialah set tiga vektor 1 0 0, 1 0 dan 0 0 1 iaitu superset
sokongan keadaan asas. Ini ansatz yang bagus.
Bayangkan kita sebaliknya pilih ansatz berbentuk ANSATZ 2 ialah a *
keadaan 1 1 0 tambah b * keadaan 011.
Ini ada sokongan yang terdiri daripada dua vektor 11 1 0 dan 011 yang tak ada pertindihan dengan sokongan keadaan asas.
Ini ansatz yang teruk.
Perhatikan bahawa kita tak semestinya perlukan ansatz menjadi anggaran yang baik bagi keadaan asas. Ansatz boleh
ada sokongan yang jauh lebih besar atau pekali boleh sangat berbeza antara ansatz dan keadaan asas sebenar dan masih berfungsi dengan baik.
Pada peringkat ini, kita dah guna ansatz yang bermotivasi baik untuk buat komputer kuantum mengamalkan keadaan yang serupa dengan sasaran kita
yang ditunjukkan di sini ialah ansatz unitary coupled gastro atau UCJ yang sangat berguna dalam kimia kuantum.
Kita sekarang nak ukur keadaan sistem untuk dapatkan rentetan bit yang menggambarkan keadaan runtuh setiap
qubit. Ingat bahawa anggaran Hamiltonian seperti dalam VQE memerlukan banyak pengukuran kuantum. Ini sebahagiannya untuk
kurangkan ketidakpastian dan sebahagiannya disebabkan bilangan kumpulan Pauli penukar yang membentuk Hamiltonian.
Dalam kaedah pensampelan, kau masih perlukan banyak pengukuran, tapi sebabnya berbeza. Sekarang, kita perlukan banyak pengukuran untuk sampel dengan berkesan
banyak keadaan asas pengiraan yang terlibat dalam keadaan kuantum yang sangat terjalin. Dalam SQD, rentetan bit yang disampel sepadan
dengan konfigurasi sistem yang disimulasikan. Kalau sistem yang dikaji tertakluk kepada kekangan mutlak seperti
hukum pemuliharaan dalam fizik atau kimia, maka kebanyakan keadaan yang diukur akan sah. Tapi beberapa rentetan bit yang disampel
sepadan dengan konfigurasi tidak sah atau tidak fizikal disebabkan hingar dan ralat. Satu proses yang dipanggil
pemulihan konfigurasi bertujuan untuk halusi sampel berhingar ini kepada set konfigurasi yang lebih tepat.
Proses ini melibatkan penjanaan konfigurasi baru dengan membalik bit secara probabilistik berdasarkan
purata penghunian orbital dan bilangan zarah yang diketahui.
Konfigurasi yang dihalusi kemudiannya digunakan untuk merentangi subruang bagi unjuran Hamiltonian dan pengedaran,
secara berulang meningkatkan ketepatan representasi keadaan kuantum.
Jom tengok contoh pemulihan konfigurasi yang kecil untuk fahami maksudnya. Andaikan kita ukur
sistem kuantum dengan empat qubit yang mewakili empat orbital molekul dan dapatkan rentetan bit berikut daripada
pemproses kuantum. Setiap rentetan bit mewakili penghunian orbital. Satu untuk
dihuni, sifar untuk tidak dihuni. Qiskit guna notasi di mana qubit paling tidak bererti ada di sebelah kanan jauh.
Contohnya, 1 0 1 0 menunjukkan bahawa orbital 1 dan tiga dihuni. Pengukuran
ini dipilih untuk tujuan pedagogi sahaja. Penghunian yang terhasil mungkin tak sepadan dengan sistem fizikal. Dalam konteks fizikal, ia
sering berlaku bahawa sistem ada bilangan zarah keseluruhan yang diketahui. Mungkin ada juga hukum pemuliharaan lain yang
boleh kau manfaatkan untuk tentukan kefizikalan keadaan yang diukur. Untuk kekal konkrit, anggaplah sistem kita
diketahui ada bilangan zarah keseluruhan n= 2. Ini memberitahu kita bilangan satu keseluruhan yang patut muncul dalam label keadaan kita
yang dipanggil kekangan berat Hamming.
Tapi, beberapa konfigurasi yang diukur melanggar kekangan ini. Keadaan 1 0 1 0 sah secara fizikal. Tapi keadaan 1 1
1 0 ada terlalu banyak zarah dan keadaan semua sifar ada terlalu sedikit zarah. Sifar
sebenarnya. Pelanggaran ini boleh disebabkan hingar dalam sistem atau ralat dalam pengukuran. Kita perlukan cara untuk balik
kepada konfigurasi yang masuk akal secara fizikal sekurang-kurangnya secara anggaran.
Ini dipanggil pemulihan konfigurasi.
Untuk betulkan sampel berhingar kita, kita balik bit secara probabilistik dalam konfigurasi tidak sah berdasarkan purata
penghunian orbital yang diambil purata ke atas konfigurasi yang sah.
Penghunian orbital ialah nilai jangkaan operator bilangan yang bertindak pada setiap orbital. Ini dianggar dan
dihalusi secara konsisten menggunakan keadaan yang dihasilkan daripada SQD. Jom tengok orbital 2 sebagai contoh. Dalam dua daripada
empat konfigurasi yang sah, orbital 2 dihuni. Ini memberi kita penghunian jangkaan 0.5.
Kita buat perkara yang sama untuk tiga orbital lain. Sekarang kita kembali ke konfigurasi tidak sah 1 1 0. Kita boleh balik salah satu
bit daripada 1 ke sifar untuk hasilkan konfigurasi yang sah. Tapi yang mana patut kita balik? Satu cara untuk putuskan ialah
melalui sisihan penghunian setiap orbital daripada purata yang baru kita kira.
Di sini kita nampak perbezaan terbesar ada dalam penghunian orbital satu. Jadi kita mungkin jangkakan bit satu patut
dibalik daripada satu ke sifar. Tentulah, orbital 2 tak jauh di belakang. Dan sentiasa mungkin, walau bagaimana pun kecil kemungkinannya, bahawa
keadaan yang diukur adalah hasil pelbagai ralat pada keadaan yang sama.
Memilih hanya sisihan terbesar daripada purata untuk semua keadaan tidak sah adalah tidak optimum. Sebaliknya, bit dibalik
secara probabilistik dengan kebarangkalian sebagai fungsi perbezaan yang ditunjukkan di sini. Anggaplah dalam kes
ini kita memang tukar bit yang paling berbeza daripada penghunian purata. Jadi 1 1 0 jadi 1 1 0 0. Kita akan buat
proses yang sama untuk pilihan tidak sah yang lain. Katakan dalam kes ini kita akhirnya membalik bit satu dan tiga.
Selepas proses pembetulan ini, kita ada set konfigurasi baru yang mungkin kelihatan seperti ini.
Menggunakan set yang dihalusi ini, kita boleh kemaskini purata penghunian orbital untuk tingkatkan ketepatan. Dalam kes kita, penghunian baru
adalah seperti ini.
Proses pemulihan berulang ini memastikan pengukuran berhingar ditapis kepada konfigurasi yang bermakna secara fizikal,
meningkatkan ketepatan anggaran keadaan eigen dalam SQD. Add-on Qiskit SQD ada beberapa alat yang
amat berguna dalam proses ini. Kalau kita dah buat kerja yang bagus mensampel keadaan dalam sokongan keadaan asas sebenar
sistem, maka kita patut boleh tengok hanya bahagian Hamiltonian yang bertindak pada subruang ini
dan masih dapatkan keadaan asas dan tenaga yang baik. Dalam contoh 4 qubit kita yang sangat kecil, pada mulanya ada 2 atau 16
keadaan sistem yang mungkin. Menggunakan gabungan pensampelan dan pemulihan konfigurasi, kita kurangkan ini
kepada tiga keadaan dalam subruang minat kita. Tiga keadaan yang kita harap membentuk sokongan keadaan asas sebenar.
Kita sekarang projek Hamiltonian penuh kita ke subruang tu. Iaitu kita buat matriks M daripada lajur vektor daripada
subruang sampel yang dipulihkan dan satu lagi yang analog M dagger daripada baris dan kita darab M dagger HM
secara bergambar. Ini bermaksud mengambil elemen matriks dalam baris dan lajur yang sepadan dengan keadaan dalam
subruang sampel yang dipulihkan. Baris dan lajur yang diserlahkan ialah yang sepadan dengan subruang kita. Dan
kotak yang diserlahkan lebih gelap di mana ia bertindih ialah elemen yang kita simpan untuk matriks yang diprojek baru kita.
Sekarang kita dah pilih subruang minat, kita boleh diagonalkan matriks ini pada komputer klasik
menggunakan penyelesai piawai. Kalau keadaan asas sebenar terdiri sepenuhnya daripada keadaan dalam subruang kita, ini
pengedaran patut hasilkan keadaan asas dan tenaga keadaan asas yang betul. Kalau kita hanya ada sebahagian besar sokongan keadaan asas
kita mungkin boleh hampiri. Sebaik kita dapat keadaan asas untuk Hamiltonian yang diprojek ini, kita ada
keadaan yang sangat berguna untuk mengira purata penghunian setiap orbital.
Sebelum ini, penghunian kita dikira daripada keadaan yang kita sampel menggunakan ansatz yang kita harap akan membantu
kita mendekati keadaan asas. Tapi tiada jaminan bahawa purata penghunian setiap orbital daripada pensampelan tu sepadan dengan penghunian
dalam keadaan tenaga terendah. Jom undur. Kita ada pensampelan keadaan pengiraan. Kita guna pemulihan konfigurasi
untuk betulkan yang tidak sah secara fizikal. Kemudian kita kira purata penghunian orbital menggunakan kesemua. The
keadaan asas mungkin hanya termasuk sebahagian daripada mereka. Keadaan asas Hamiltonian yang diprojek ini mungkin bukan keadaan asas sebenar
sistem asal kita, tapi ia adalah keadaan tenaga terendah yang boleh dicipta menggunakan mana-mana superposisi
keadaan yang dipulihkan dalam subruang kita. Penghunian orbital keadaan ini akan hasilkan tenaga yang kurang daripada atau sama dengan
tenaga penghunian yang diperolehi daripada ruang yang dipulihkan. Jadi penghunian ini adalah anggaran yang lebih baik bagi
penghunian keadaan asas. Kita boleh ulangi proses pemulihan konfigurasi menggunakan penghunian baru ini dan kita boleh ulang
ini sehingga kriteria penumpuan kita dipenuhi. Pengedaran kuantum berasaskan sampel lebih pantas berbanding
algoritma jangka dekat lain seperti VQE. Ia lebih berskala dan kukuh terhadap hingar dan ralat dalam pensampelan. Ia masih
memerlukan kita menyediakan ansatz yang bagus dengan unjuran yang besar di bawah sokongan keadaan asas sebenar sistem kita. Kalau tak ada langsung yang diketahui
tentang keadaan asas sebenar kita, SQD mungkin perlu digunakan bersama kaedah lain untuk mula-mula ketahui tentang
keadaan asas dan hampiri secara berulang.
SQD memainkan peranan kritikal dalam suite algoritma hibrid klasik-kuantum yang sedang berkembang dan merupakan salah satu
pemacu terbesar menuju pengkomputeran kuantum yang berguna.